now the memos describe former FBI
director Comey's private interactions
with President Trump and the big
question is whether Comey leaked any
classified information to the press
here's what he said a short time ago
after the memos were made public I'm
sure the Special Counsel is considering
my recollection of those events which
are reflected in these memos but it's my
recollection that is the evidence that
will be used if there was ever a
proceeding these would be to show that I
wrote it down at the time sort of the
bolster the credibility of my
recollection now to sort this out and
tell us what's inside let's bring in
Republican congressman Chris Stewart a
member of the House Intel committee
congressman do you mean give us the take
well you know what it shows me and we
haven't had a chance to go through all
of it and most people haven't but it
shows me that the director Comey was
dishonest with the president from the
very beginning and continues to be well
for example he should have gone in and
said mr. president we have this this
piece of political garbage it was funded
by the DNC it was funded by Hillary
Clinton paid no attention to it and if
anyone brings it up will refute it will
say it's not credible he said later on
it was salacious unverified he should
have said that in stronger words instead
what he said to the president is the
Russians are reporting as if this was a
credible Russian intelligence operation
when he knew that it wasn't he knew that
this was that some formal document the
Russian intelligence had created and put
together it was put together by Hillary
Clinton in the DNC who used a foreign
agent by the way who used second and
third-hand information from unidentified
Russians that we don't even know who
they were he should have been honest
with the president and by the way he's
being dishonest with the president
continuing he says that he thinks it's
possible that the president is under
some type of shadow that the Russians
have some information to walk that back
a little bit well he should have walked
it back because it spot was outrageous
performer he's got information on you
and on me and director Comey and but
that's where that's the position he's
taken on this say he's trying to cast as
deep a shadow as he possibly could over
this broad memos to the file are
invariably self-serving documents I
remember when I was a white-collar
criminal defense attorney
you always look at those like let's go
over
really you know okay you're not gonna
write a memo to the file that makes you
look like a fool or makes you look like
a liar or makes it makes you look like
you're misrepresenting the facts you're
gonna write a memo to the file that
memorializes events in a way that
usually will make you look the best in
the best light there was an interesting
part of this one of these memos it's not
very long they you you have the
unredacted redacted version this is what
he says in one of the memos he said I
had dinner with President Trump in the
green room at the White House last night
at 6:30 p.m. I explained that he could
always count on me to tell the truth I
said I don't do sneaky things I don't
leak I don't do weasel moves what was
that
releasing the memo to the Columbia
professor to release it to the media was
that leaking or was that just you know
tiddlywinks well and it's not the way a
direct FBI director should should
respond or should act and and to be
dishonest about it and I got to tell you
Laura too that the testimony the
director has provided before the
committee in closed sessions does not
comport at all with some of the things
that he's saying publicly right now I
know you can't discuss this because it's
a closed session it's right or is it
already out there because it hasn't been
but we hope it will be and it should be
and by the way this is another good
example of information that should have
been released the first time we asked
why in the world does the Department of
Justice feel like it's their
responsibility to protect this person
rather than their responsibility would
be to be open and honest with the
American people now there's another part
of this memo where President Trump
rightly as you did in the campaign calls
into question Andrew McCabe and at that
point he says at about this point he
asked me again about your guy McCabe and
that does sound like Trump and whether
he was going to be okay I again affirmed
Andy's ability and professionalism and
said the president would come to see him
and benefit from both at that point he
already knew that Andrew McCabe probably
had some problems yet he was telling the
president that McCabe was fine yeah and
you know it there's a brings me to
another question that is how is it that
the director of the FBI had surrounded
himself with what we know now are
political hacks Andrew McCabe mr. Pete
Stark Lisa Paige others look
FBI isn't full of progressives it's not
full of liberal activists and yet
they're around director it sure seemed
like he had selected and advanced and
promoted people that certainly had a
different view than many America are you
gonna bring call me back up we sure hope
so how you gonna how you gonna make that
happen well he's going to be we're gonna
request that he come and speak before
the committee and I explained if he gets
to the house you see and say I expect
he's gonna decline
I can't imagine he's gonna be maybe you
should just hang out one of the green
rooms upstairs because he's it's pretty
much at MSNBC I think he has a little
binky and a little little sleeping bag
up there he's staying up there a lot so
you just go up there and interview he's
been pretty effective at selling his
book there's no doubt about it but you
know this is not about his book this is
about learning the truths and having him
be accountable for some of the things
that he said again I don't expect he's
going to be banging on our door and
volunteering to come but if he doesn't
why won't he he's a very smart guy
University of Chicago Law School
incredible career in the government I
mean he's a really she's a smart guy if
he can't withstand questioning from you
congressman and some of these other guys
he goes on with all these tough guy
journalists I mean he can't withstand
your questions